from the National Geographic
headquarters in Washington DC
welcome to the 29th National Geographic
Bee what are we doing here
the 4th grade I was a participant of the
GOP so I might be pretty good at it so
let's go
Friday more than 40 species of cacti can
be found in the Guadalupe Mountains
located in a desert that extends from
Mexico into Texas New Mexico and Arizona
named this desert skip that we get to
pass it's for Wallman desert that is
correct
beta Alaska's Koontz new wilderness area
located on Admiralty Island has one of
the highest concentrations of brown
bears in the world this wilderness area
lies 50 miles south of what important
city Fairbanks I didn't study I should
have studied more people actually get
these kids get these Juno Juno the
correct answer that is right did you
know yeah do you know no Fairbanks
do you know Juna Juna i'il on the
Glacial forces that created the
waterways and rocky outcrops that define
the Boundary Waters Canoe Area
Wilderness also created a large lake
near its eastern border named this lake
repeat the question
repeat the question please which is the
next question
is it one of the five greatly who is
supposed to get these superior yeah Lake
Superior
it makes appear that is the superior
answer yes the Oder River flows through
a lagoon into what see the see the
flowing nature Baltic Sea the Baltic Sea
you are the Black Sea Baltic
that's what I said isla de la juventud
is part of which country dealer what I'm
going to say Brazil that's right
scientists are planning to reintroduce
Tigers to Central Asia fifty years after
they became extinct in the region one
potential site for reintroduction is the
Almaty region in which country I was not
paying attention what do you have
Kazakhstan the correct answer is
Kazakhstan ready kazakhstan kazakhstan
let me know when they do the general
accepted accounting principle quiz that
i'll come back down
[Music]